[Musique]
bonjour merci d'être avec nous pour un
nouveau rendez vous de dimanche en
politique rendez vous exceptionnel
aujourd'hui dans le cadre de la semaine
de l'éducation nous sommes vous le voyez
au lycée charles de gaulle a dit jean et
c'est la vie des jeunes la vie des
lycéens qui nous intéresse ont-ils envie
de s'engager
ont-ils envie de faire changer les
choses se sentent ils compris ils vont
nous le dire ils échangeront avec des
élus de jeunes élus et responsables
associatifs qui étaient à leur place il
n'y a pas si longtemps et d'ancêtres
tombe du lycée arnaut vous êtes avec nos
lycéens qui ce matin sont un peu chez
eux ici c'est vrai ils préparent le bac
puisqu'ils sont en terminale or le bac
ça va occuper une grande partie de leur
année mais nous allons voir avec eux
c'est ça laisse un petit peu de temps
pour d'autres engagements associatifs
peut-être on a donné la parole pour
commencer à l'iss c'est l'engagement
plus tôt dans la vie du lycée pour toi
oui exactement j'ai su suis engagée
depuis deux ans déjà au sein de la vie
associative de mon lycée où j'ai été élu
au conseil de vie lycéenne par mes
camarades l'année dernière ainsi qu'à la
mde est donc la maison des lycéens on
prépare tous les projets associatifs qui
font la notoriété de l'ulis était vraie
élection à bulletins secrets comme un
vrai scrutin dans la vraie vie
exactement
donc tu connais un petit peu ce que
c'est que la politique entre guillemets
même s'il n'y a pas forcément besoin
d'être candidat si forcément aussi
sicilien prépare une profession de foi
on se présente en tant que candidat et
on est élu par nos candidats au sein
dudit maël c'est la vie aussi du lycée
qui te qui t'intéresse
oui c'est bien ça je suis avec alice je
suis vice-président du conseil de la vie
du lycée je suis aussi bénévole dans une
association
ponctuellement une association de
quartier dépendante de léo lagrange à
bella pour toi c'est quoi l'engagement
pour moi mon engagement est plutôt
culturelle à c'est à dire que je
m'investis dans les activités
artistiques du lait c'est comme la danse
et le théâtre mais aussi au niveau de
mon engagement personnel je m'engage
dans le club qui qui qui qui va
améliorer les empreintes écologiques du
lycée et aussi dans un club qui recrée
les une question de la son écologie
environnement ne reparlera dans le
courant de cette émission peeling toi
seul théâtre exactement bas appareil
comme ab là on est dans le club théâtre
donc c'est vrai qu'il ya vraiment une
cohésion une
depuis l'équipe et on s'entraide de tous
pour pouvoir faire le plus beau
spectacle à la fin de l'année et il ya
aussi d'autres clubs comme le club
amnistie donc en fait où on signe des
pétitions pour venir en aide aux gens
qui ont été victimes de l'injustice
culture environnement et puis donc un
petit peu de politique pas forcément au
sein d'un parti d'ailleurs les lions vos
invités ne sont pas forcément eux aussi
tombés dans un parti politique quand il
était petit ils vont nous le dire
effectivement quatre invités avec tout
sur ce plateau en vous cacherais vous
avez vu l'image à l'étagé en dessous en
fait on est dans la rotonde est tout
près les tout près les uns des autres
on a fait une sélection par l'âge tout à
fait assumé ce matin vous êtes jeune
vous aussi justin guyot maire de decize
dans la nièvre
bonjour bonjour vincent chauvet bonjour
maire d'autun saône-et-loire
je vous êtes membre du modem alexandre
emorine bonjour bonjour vous militez
sous les couleurs de la france insoumise
en côte-d'or et bilel ben elle m'a dit
bonjour vous avez créé à chalon
l'association site et créatif vous êtes
notre associatif jour une association
qui aide les jeunes à tourner des courts
métrages dans l'eure
c'est ça dans leur site et vous allez
vous allez nous l'expliqué retour au
lycée pour vous ça fait quoi justin
guyot
à leur âge 17 18 ans vous pensiez au bac
où vous vouliez changer le monde ou
diriger une ville à 17 ans je pensais
déjà obtenir mon bac
donc j'ai obtenu d'ailleurs c'est vrai
que j'étais pas du tout politiser
j'étais totalement déconnectée de tout
de tout aspect politique ceux du camp
c'est mieux quand je suis arrivé à la
faculté en 2008 et donc j'ai été
confronté au mouvement contre la loi
pécresse donc avec quelques amis nous
avons milité on a fait partie à de
l'unef et donc de là est partie de là
est partie de l'engagement de belmadi
vous aussi ça fait pas très longtemps
que vous étiez au lycée c'était comment
quand vous y étiez vous aviez déjà envie
de créer une association de faire des
choses vous habiller le sentiment que il
fallait le faire ou en fait pas du tout
à cet âge là en fait c'est assez
compliqué parce que à cet âge-là je
voulais passer le bac et j'avais
l'impression qu'il fallait que je passe
le bac et j'étais un peu perdue parce
que je sais pas trop quoi faire on ne
proposait pas forcément ce qu'on veut et
c'est venu un peu plus tard en fait
enfin je voulais m'engager un peu plus
tard d'abord le bac et après alors c'est
un peu un sondage sur les quatre
politisés ou pas quand vous entendez
voilà on a entendu quatre jeunes alors
y'a de l'associatif ya du culturel il ya
des choses un peu plus politique on le
sent derrière c'était comment pour vous
j'étais très politisé puisque à 16 ans
j'ai pris ma carte dans un vieux parti
qui n'existe plus s'appelle l'udf qui
est devenu le modem
ensuite et moi je voulais pas changer le
monde peut changer l'europe puisque en
2005 c'était le référendum pour la
constitution européenne
donc je coller des affiches avaient
participé à des émissions de radio
amateur 1 des débats dans des cafés pour
la constitution européenne
j'ai entendu certains mots clés qui
m'ont réveillé des souvenirs amnesty et
on le voit toujours à autun le club
amnesty travaille beaucoup avec les
réfugiés par exemple j'ai entendu modèle
nations unies ou modèle l'union
européenne c'est à dire des jeunes qui
essaient de reproduire les conseils
européens
le conseil de sécurité ça aussi c'est
des choses que j'ai connu et puis le cvl
je pense qu est la base regard délégués
de classe et puis ensuite au conseil de
la vie lycéenne avec je me souvienne
vraie campagne on avait des tracts de
personnes d'opinion politique totalement
différente mais vraiment une vraie
duquel je vois tellement de façons voit
dans nos lycées aussi des différences
vont leur parcours et dans ce moment là
et puis il ya ceux qui on en plaisante
et avant l'émission élections des
marines sont tombés dedans tout petit
puisque vous avez un papa qui était
maire d'une commune lui-même est très
engagé en politique
alors ça s'agit d'un forcément quand on
dit ça joue forcément moi c'est vrai
qu'à 17 ans je pensais à passer mon bac
également mais on était en 2007 on était
pendant la campagne présidentielle
donc j'étais engagé alors à l'époque au
parti socialiste ça a changé depuis mais
en tout cas voilà j'étais déjà engagé à
17 ans tout en essayant de mener de
front aussi également les études et puis
ensuite pas l'engagement s'est
approfondie en arrivant à l'université
pareil j'ai participé au mouvement
étudiant qui ont eu lieu sur le sol
signé sur le sur le campus contre la loi
pécresse
et puis ensuite bal engagement seul
engagement continu et et alors il ya
peut-être une histoire de tradition
familiale mais je pense qu'il est avant
tout une histoire de conviction
personnelle est de mise en accord avec
avec mes opinions l'impression d'être
plutôt raccord avec ce que vous entendez
ici ce matin à ne pas être très
déconnecté finalement de cette
génération là est-ce que vous avez
l'impression à son chevet vous êtes
alors il va nous falloir l'émission pour
en être sûr pour s'en rendre compte mais
qu'il ya quelque chose de commun je
pense qu'il ya ce qui a beaucoup changé
c'est l'émergence des réseaux sociaux
facebook est né après après l'essai et
nous on n'avait pas ce genre de choses
sur ce conscientiser pour se mobiliser
et donc je pense que ça joue vraiment un
nouveau rôle dans l'éveil politique des
jeunes est justement de nouveaux défis
aussi pour lutter contre l'effet que
nous à lutter contre les effets de
bulles pour que les gens voyaient venir
effectivement parce que c'est un des
chapitres qu'on a décidé d'explorer avec
eux et avec vous sur comment les jeunes
aujourd'hui s'informer et de forger leur
opinion
il ya un point très simple en fait pour
commencer tout ça c'est que un certain
nombre
lycéens vont voter aux prochaines
élections arnaud je crois qu'ils sont
autour de vous oui 18 ans c'est un âge
important l'âge de la majorité même si
désormais on peut passer le permis de
conduire avant donc escale à 18 ans ça
change vraiment la vie dans nos lycéens
qui a déjà 18 ans il n'a t-il je fais la
main oui quelques-uns win qui aura l'âge
de voter par exemple 18 ans pour les
prochains scrutins donc l'an prochain
n'a quelques-uns aussi et ben on va voir
si ça les intéresse chahine par exemple
avoir 18 ans est ce que tu vois ça comme
un cap parce que tu te sens plus
responsable est ce que tu penses que ça
va changer quelque chose dans ta vie
finalement je suis pas sûr qu'on ressent
particulièrement plus responsables au
quai a vraiment un cap de franchi
puisque finalement resté à peu près dans
le même temps m cocon dont nous on reste
trop lisse et je vais pas changer de
d'endroits où radicalement ou voir ma
vie changer du jour au lendemain il ya
la partie où on peut voter
officiellement légalement mais en dehors
de ça souvent les 18 en tout cas pour
comment je pense que ça va se passer et
comment s'est passé pour les personnes
que je connais c'est pas du tout plu du
tout un cap on passe du jour au
lendemain d'une ville à une autre mais
effectivement il ya cette histoire de
voter ce qu'il y en a qui sont sûrs
d'aller voter pour les européennes pour
les municipales ensuite en 2020 pas
forcément
wima lc oui oui moi je pense que c'est
important d'aller voter parce que pour
les élections présidentielles c'est à
l'échelle de la france donc c'est plus
proche des citoyens mais on oublie
l'union européenne il faut quand même
aller voter parce que même si c'est plus
loin il faut quand même faire part de
son opinion est le moyen le plus
efficace et le vote pour dire bah
quelles parties on est où
qu'est ce qu'on souhaite adhérer alors
c'est important ce que tu dis tu es
citoyens dijonnais bourguignon français
tu te sens aussi européens ah oui parce
qu'on est dans manon née en 2001 on est
né en 2001 donc on est né dans l'union
européenne est comparé à nos parents qui
sont convenus l'union européenne
arrivent et moi je me sens un plus
européen et tu en parles peut-être avec
tes parents de cette construction
européenne
toi tu l'as vu effectivement déjà bâti
il te raconter comment ça c'est fait
mon rap ont ils m'ont raconté mais plus
particulièrement les points négatifs
quand même avec le vote de 2005 ou des
choses comme ça qui se sont passées qui
était pas forcément bas très bien
accepté mais il faut aussi voir les
points positifs comme la paix dans dans
le sur l'europe sur le continent
européen
la paix l'union douanière tout ça va je
pense que c'est important de voir sa
ligne tu a levé la main aussi tu vas
aller voter et bien sûr parce que je
pense que voter c'est un droit
fondamental et pense qu'on peut pas
exprimer son désaccord s'il n'a pas
donné son opinion par un vote
est ce que l inverse n'a qui se disent
non pas très peu pour moi je passerai
mon tour où je m'abstiendrai est ce que
vous voulez bien le dire si c'est le cas
vous pas a priori n'auront donc plus tôt
des citoyens qui ont voté
que ce soit pour les européennes où les
autres scrutins à venir
un merci arnaud effectivement on a
entendu des gens qui vont voter mais moi
j'ai envie de vous dire en particulier
aux élus locaux
globalement c'est pas eux qui votent
pour vous en fait les jeunes votre peut
on le sait aux élections je suis tout à
fait à 2,6 effectivement les jeunes
représentent un tiers de la population
et lors des dernières élections
municipales dont qui a été en 2018 les
jeunes ne sont pas du tout aller voter
se sont très peu mobilisé alors pourtant
j'étais pour eux une sorte de porte
parole de la jeunesse de 6 was et a
contrario ils ne sont jamais ils ne se
sont pas déplacés aux urnes ce qui est
assez contradictoire et on sent des
jeunes totalement déconnecté du monde
dans votre journée de mer effectivement
vous croisez des jeunes de votre commune
vous leur en parler de ça de l'élection
du ventoux où le sait pas si facile de
d'échangés finalement
avec des jeunes sur vous et allez voter
vous votez vous votez pas je pense qu'on
a des jeunes qui sont quand même assez
individualiste il est très difficile de
leur imposer quoi que ce soit
effectivement je vais leur dire qu'il
est important d'aller voter que le vote
est un droit mais presque un devoir mais
fondamentalement s'ils ne veulent pas
aller voter ils ne font pas bilal
belmadi ça fait partie l'engagement le
fait de participer
ça fait partie de votre de votre action
en tout cas quelque chose c'est quelque
chose que vous vous observez au
quotidien dans votre activité
oui parce que derrière ce projet
justement de cinéma on essaye de faire
bouger les choses
donc moi j'ai grandi avec des jeunes qui
je leur parle j'ai c'est de savoir ce
qu'ils veulent ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est qu'on est tous différents et c'est
difficile de satisfaire tout le monde
donc on essaie de prendre les points
clés et de pouvoir améliorer ces
choses-là par rapport à ce qu'enfin
grâce à ce qu'on aime le vote s'est pas
forcément le truc le plus facile on va
dire pour les amener à réfléchir sur ce
qui est autour d'eux déjà cotée qu'on
entame en politique ça freine
directement les jeunes et je pense que
c'est au niveau de la communication il
faut améliorer la transition et déjà
c'est enfin comme vous l'avez dit ça ça
avance très vite et les réseaux sociaux
et puis il ya un risque c'est de
désinformation donc faut vraiment faire
attention à tout ça et puis justement
savoir comment communiquer avec eux et
faire attention au monde qui bouge on va
on va essayer de comprendre d'ailleurs
pour ce qu'ils peuvent faire comme ils
peuvent le faire
on profite d'avoir un autre maire jean
chauvet vous aussi quand vous êtes élu
maire finalement même si on en reparlera
aussi mais si vous faites des choses en
direction de la jeunesse pour autant
c'est pas eux qui vont vous faire gagner
une élection
non mais c'est important de les
mobiliser et aussi d'avoir des
professeurs une communauté éducative
dans les lycées qui mobilise on a créé
de 6 aussi un conseil des jeunes
citoyens qui en fait un conseil
municipal des jeunes qui marche très
bien et on a la particularité d'avoir un
lycée militaire ou le sens de la
citoyenneté va plus loin même que le
vote et et l'engagement politique
puisque c'est un engagement personnel
pour la france et
dans ce cadre un certain nombre
d'actions qui sont menées notamment lors
des commémorations patriotiques ou lors
des grands événements fédérateurs où on
arrive à avoir cet esprit de citoyenneté
qui souffle quand même dans la ville par
ces établissements le lycée bonaparte
aussi qui pousse pour l'engagement des
jeunes au service de la cité et du bien
commun dans l'engagement avec le lycée
militaire arrêté un stade encore
supérieur à l'envoi où on est
aujourd'hui avec pas mal de jeunes qui
s'engagent et qui sont pas forcément
faut le dire représentatif de toute la
population des jeunes en france
en france alexandre emorine le vote le
fait de ne pas participer c'est quelque
chose que vous ressentez aussi aussi
fortement en se disant en réfléchissant
peut-être vous dans votre partie aussi à
rendre au comment on va aller les
chercher où comment on peut leur parler
à ces jeunes bien sûr c'est quelque
chose qu'on ressent alors on sait que la
france insoumise arrive première chez
les jeunes dans toutes les élections
depuis depuis 2000 17 mai à côté si vous
regardez les dernières élections
partielles par exemple en essonne qu'il
ait eu lieu seulement 18 % de votants
c'est à dire que 80 2 % des gens n'ont
pas voté
jeunes et moins jeunes d'ailleurs y'a
pas que la jeunesse qui ne va pas voter
il ya également toute une frange de la
société qui se met dans une véritable
grève civique aujourd'hui et ça pourquoi
je pense pas qu'il faille culpabiliser
un petit peu les joyeux disant qu'ils
sont il faudrait pas que la suisse était
un témoignage arabia a généré cette
image il faut vraiment pas culpabiliser
les gens les gens qui n'ont pas voté par
contre il faut expliquer peut-être
pourquoi peut-être parce que depuis
trente ans les parties elle est partie
je dirais institutionnels ou de
gouvernement ont pu instiller le doute
dans les têtes que voter ça ne servait
plus à rien puisque au final la même
politique allait s'appliquer que l'on
vous promet le changement et qu'au final
vous avez la même politique qu'avant
donc ça il faut impérativement y
répondre alors nous on a plusieurs
solutions en tout cas on a proposé plus
lent chaussures le débat on à la
redéfinition des règles du jeu sur une
manière nationale 1 avec l'assemblée
constituante le passage à une sixième
république beaucoup plus participative
également pour les citoyens mais aussi
sur un point très très factuelle quelque
chose qui emmanuel macron pourrait faire
lui-même c'est-à-dire aller non mais
c'est une vraie proposition politique
c'est l'obligation du vote le droit le
droit le droit de vote obligatoire c'est
quelque chose qui est le cas en victoire
en 10 mai elle très longtemps mais avec
une vraie reconnaissance du vote blanc
parce qu'aujourd'hui il arrive
bien entendu que des gens ne se sentent
pas représentés par l'offre politique
qui leur est proposé il faut que ces
gens puissent avoir une voix qui porte à
égalité avec avec les autres et donc
reconnaître le vote blanc aujourd'hui je
pense que c'est une mesure démocratique
obligatoire car non le faire est ce que
c'est le lien pour la suite ou sur le
vote blanc assemat elle qui a réagi
quand justin guyot parler d'une faible
engagement des jeunes quand alexandre
noreen elle venait pas légalement aussi
de la fal de participation des jeunes
dans la vie politique
malte a titillé jeunes impression oui
parce que madame guillou vous avez dit
que les jeunes étaient plus individuel
je pense pas que ce soit je conçois que
ce soit ça faut pas faire de généralités
parce que tous les jeunes ne sont pas
comme ça il ya pas mal de jeunes qui
vont aller voter
personnellement ma soeur je les force à
aller voter c'est vrai mais avant tout
on s'est renseigné avant tout on a on a
vu de la communication avant tout on a
analysé les différents programmes parce
que c'est un manque de communication
c'est un manque d'intérêt
les jeunes ont un manque d'intérêt parce
que ouais c'est tout le temps la même
chose c'est tout le temps les mêmes
politiques c'est toutefois les mêmes
personnalités qui reviennent sur la
scène politique et du coup il ya un
frein et je pense qu'il faut avoir plus
de communication être plus proche des
jeunes développer des nouveaux médias
comme voilà instagram des choses comme
ça qui touche plus les jeunes que
maintenant facebook
je pense que voilà c'est ça qui il faut
pas faire de généralités sur surtout les
jeunes comme quoi ils ne vont pas voter
ils ne sont pas reconnaissants ça je
pense que c'est faux la plupart des
jeunes ne vont pas voter évidemment neil
back on a d'autres choses à faire on a
on a des partiels on a des balles
blanches
on a beaucoup de devoirs travail et le
fait qu'on n'aille pas voter c'est pas
du tout parce que voilà à ces sept
personnes qui se présentent je le veux
pas aller voter c'est passant on en
reparlera tout à l'heure mais
effectivement ça veut dire que parfois
les politiques ne parlent pas aux jeunes
n'ont pas de la bonne façon ça ce
sentiment que tu vois je pense qu'ils
essaient de parler aux jeunes et c'est
des efforts qu'on constate mais ils s'y
prennent pas de la bonne manière et je
pense que la communication est
primordiale pour s'adresser aux jeunes
il ya une communication spécifique qui
pourrait nous toucher on est là
justement pour rétablir les liens cette
communication je pense un petit mot
avant de passer à la suite parce qu'on
en a prévu pas mal de pas mal de choses
un petit mot de justice après
bien je vois que ma elle s'est forgé une
opinion dont je vais lui répondre
rapidement sur sur le fait que les
politiques n'écoutent pas forcément la
jeunesse moi je ne dis pas que les
jeunes ne sont absolument pas
reconnaissant mais je pense
qu'effectivement on est dans un contexte
de crise politique et de confiance
politique depuis déjà trente ans et les
jeunes vont faire leurs premiers pas
citoyens dans une crise politique où ils
n'ont ni confiance en la droite ni
confiance en la gauche et ils n'ont pas
l'impression d'être entendus par des
élites politiques et je pense que c'est
avant tout pour ça aussi qu'ils ont du
mal à appréhender le vote alors on sort
du vote et on passe à l'engagement
c'était aussi le thème de notre de notre
journée en fait changer le monde ou
changer le quotidien finalement arnaud
c'est la question qu'ont souhaité poser
aux élèves du lycée charles de gaulle
qu'est ce qui les motive finalement
changé des grandes choses ou ou changer
des petites choses c'est vrai est ce que
l'intéressement est aussi dans
l'engagement se servir les autres est-ce
aussi se servir soi même ou la journée
dans le sujet de philo va garder secrète
pour la guadeloupe
on va revenir à des considérations
peut-être un peu plus simple
les raisons de l'engagement alors
peut-être si on commence par artois
yasmine je pense qu'on peut s'engager
pour plusieurs choses mais s'engager
pour se servir soi même je pense que
c'est un mauvais motifs d'engagement et
faut revoir son engagement quand on veut
seulement servir on peut avoir en tête
l'idée que ça peut servir sa future
carrière aussi c'est tout à fait louable
oui bien sûr mais que quand on s'engage
politiquement je pense qu'il faut plus
penser collectif qu'individuel
grégoire peut-être sur ce sujet aussi je
pense que lorsqu'on s'engage dans une
cause il faut s'engager à 100% et non
pas de manière partielle histoire de
voile à s'engager pour s'engager mais il
faut être bas dans ses convictions et
s'engager pour une cause que l'on trouve
juste et que l'on est prêt à défendre
jusqu'au bout il y en a par exemple des
quotas dans l'actualité des choses qui
semblent à défendre dans mon état
d'esprit actuel je n'irai pas m'engager
pour des choses dont je ne m'intéresse
pas forcément voilà tout ce qui est le
mouvement des gilet jaune
je pensais au départ que ces lettres une
une cause qu'elle est servi de manière
juste mais a vu les débordements actuels
je ne pense pas parce que c'est
peut-être la première façon de voir des
gens dans la rue pour vous qui êtes
jeunes vous ai pas connu mais 68
évidemment c'est un mouvement qui vous
semble voilà qui vous comment vous
l'observez finalement vous à travers le
prisme soit de la télé ou des réseaux
sociaux de manière actuelle je trouve
que le mouvement des jeunes est plus un
mouvement en vain je n'y vois que des
gens qui malheureusement kick ass qui
dégradent les lieux publics et je ne
vois plus des gens qui utilisent leurs
voix pour s'élever
voilà pour cette impression en tout cas
sur ce mouvement et sur l'engagement
duval belmadi quand on travaille avec
les jeunes comme vous qu'est ce qui les
motive à travailler avec vous au sein de
sites et créatif c'est sait faire parler
d'eux c'est faire changer leur quartier
il ya une dimension quartier très forte
je crois on disait collectifs
individuels des grandes causes des
petites causes c'est quoi qui fonctionne
ce qui fonctionne pas c'est que ben on
les comprend en fait directement on
essaie de on les laisse rêver on les
laisse une certaine liberté tout en
contrôlant justement parce que il ya un
danger que les réseaux sociaux c'est à
dire que tout va très vite et il ya
risque de désinformation comme je disais
tout à l'heure et puis donc on essaie de
contrôler mais on essaie aussi de leur
donner la parole
et ce qui leur fait rêver c'est cette
faire des films c'est de s'amuser c2 et
justement on essaie de mélanger un peu
les deux de leur montrer qu'on peut
faire changer les choses mais tout en
faisant ce qu'on n'allant pas trop loin
dans on va dire le militantisme là c'est
avec ça que vous essayez de jouer aussi
je ne sais pas de prendre position
quelque part on n'essaye pas de de leurs
forces et quelques de leurs de forcer à
faire quelque chose on leur dit venez
vous amuser venez on va écrire quelque
chose ensemble mais ça sera votre film
ce sera et ils se sentent valorisés
parce que c'est leur film à eux et voilà
c'est le collectif qui marchent alors du
coup là aussi c'est nazi du collectif
bien sûr c'est positif parce que on se
rend compte que tout seul on va pas loin
à un moment donné où ça va ça va bloquer
et puis le seul moyen d'aller plus loin
c'est justement d'être ensemble et de
faire abstraction de toutes les limites
en fait deux donc c'est très important
d'être de penser collectif
vous évoquiez tout à l'heure la base la
structure même de ce qui se fait dans
les lycées ils nous disaient ce qu'ils
faisaient
c'est quoi ces de votre point de vue
l'apprentissage de de la suite de deux
des changements qu'on veut obtenir de
façon plus sociétale ça ne peut se
commencé au lycée ça peut commencer là
ça doit commencer au lycée et puis ça
doit aussi se poursuivre dans
l'engagement communal vous savez ce que
disait tocqueville le grand philosophe
du libéralisme
décidément on est très bas qu station à
ressortir c'était cet été disaient les
communes sont à la démocratie ce que
l'école est à la science elle la met à
la portée du peuple et c'est exactement
ce qu'on voit et nous en tant qu'élus
locaux on a un vrai rôle à jouer par
rapport à cette crise de confiance au
niveau national on peut se dire
effectivement qu'est ce qui changera pas
de deux d'impact sur notre quotidien
au niveau local quand on décide de
construire une piste d'athlétisme quand
on décide de vendre un bâtiment pour
faire un laser game quand on décide de
refaire telle route et pâle ou tel autre
c'est des vrais choix collectifs et nous
par exemple pour intéresser les jeunes
on a décidé de mettre le conseil
municipal en direct sur facebook
le prochain et le 30 novembre et donc
les gens peuvent poser des questions et
puis les jeunes peuvent suivre aussi ou
revoir ce qui a été décidé et commenté
on doit probablement aller plus loin en
allant sur instagram ça a été cité slap
shot et avoir des formats peut-être plus
court et plus simple qu'un conseil
municipal qui peut durer deux ou trois
heures mais c'est sûr qu'il faut revoir
notre mode de communication vis-à-vis
des jeunes le conseil jeune citoyen est
là pour ça il faut aussi que les jeunes
sachent qu'ils peuvent aller dans les
conseils communautaires dans les
conseils municipaux qui peuvent aussi
s'impliquer et aussi aux cérémonies
patriotiques il ya aussi un devoir
d'aller de sortir de chez soi quand la
mère de 2,6 disait qu'il y avait un
individualisme c'est aussi peut-être un
repli sur soi et et des jeunes qui
s'engagent ni dans les associations ni
dans la vie de la cité c'est important
c'est de sortir et d'aller rencontrer
l'autre
dire sans trop se tromper qui à une
époque aussi où il était de bon ton en
politique municipale d'aller chercher
des jeunes d'avoir des jeunes
il fallait un jeune il fallait une femme
falla sportifs et des choses comme ça
alexandre emorine ce que vous êtes en
train de nous dire c'est que si on veut
que vraiment ils participent ils
s'intéressent et qui comprenne c'est pas
comme ça qu'il faut faire
je pense que c'est pas c'est pas aux
jeunes à s'adapter aux structures qui
existent déjà
c'est pas eux qui doivent rentrer dans
un moule c'est la société
enfin ce sont les structures de la
société qui doivent s'adapter également
à la composition de la société la
structure de s'adapter donc aujourd'hui
à la jeunesse parce qu'aujourd'hui alors
vous déplorez à l'individualisme
enfin oui je suis assez choqué en fait
quand j'entends ça les jeunes ne
demandent qu'à s'engager
vous avez énormément de cause tout à
l'heure on entendait parler d'écologie
avait énormément de jeunes sur les
marchands le climat il ya encore une
d'ailleurs le 8 décembre
hier il avait une manifestation dans si
statistiquement on fait un sondage dont
toutes les classes de terminale de
france suis pas sûr qu'on va arriver à
un pourcentage très élevé et sans jouer
au vieux ses trois petits points
dans les années 80 on sait qu'il ya une
politisation beaucoup plus forte dans
les lycées beaucoup plus forte dans
certains endroits on le sait c'est vrai
peut-être parce qu'à l'époque y avait
encore de l'espoir chez certains partis
et ces partis ont déçu depuis et on a vu
que depuis 2010 est leur audience est
quand même très fortement réduite donc
pour revenir sur la question
d'engagement lierre y avait des
manifestations contre les violences
sexuelles et sexistes y avait énormément
de jeunes qui se mobilisaient sur ces
questions là parce que la question de
l'égalité la question de l'écologie j'en
parlais juste avant ça ce sont des
questions qui sont structurantes pour la
jeunesse et pour répondre également
alors je me rappelle plus de son prénom
sur la question des idées jaune
attention à ne pas voir que les casseurs
dans les gilet jaune
il faut voir également ses gilet jaune
qui a pas très loin d'ici à chevigny ont
distribué le surplus alimentaires ou sdf
les casseurs ne sont déjà peut-être pas
forcément des gelées jaune et c'est un
mouvement qui est protéiforme et qui
relève énormément de réalité on remonte
à l'étagé
arnaud alors réaction à ce qu'on vient
de dire sur l'individualisme sur
l'obligation de s'adapter ou on avance
sur quel est le meilleur la meilleure
structure pour s'engager
peut-être qu'on dit le guen va répondre
et puis à prendre un mini débat dans le
débat en train très bien et chez reed
sur l'engagement des jeunes ou pas
c'était juste pour réagir dans quelques
secondes face à voile assez gilet jaune
c'est très bien de distribuer volait de
la nourriture et des messins problème
c'est qu'on ne montre pas on préfère
nous montrer des images choquantes par
exemple de l'avenue des champs-elysées
qui est dégradée
plutôt que des gilets jaunes qui nous
qui aide vraiment le peuple
alors après aux bourses et un aspect
médiatique aussi il s'est passé des
choses sont désocialisées s'est passé
des choses a dit van riet rossi la
distribution ou de effectivement faut
aussi nous elle
le message c'est que on est là aussi
pour montrer effectivement ses bonnes
actions
encore faut-il qu'on soit au courant
qu'elle existe chahine toi t'es pas
forcément emballé par l'idée que les
jeunes s'engagent qui sont pas forcément
tous engagés tu vois aussi des gens
autour de toi qui n'ont pas grand chose
à faire de ce qui se passe autour d'eux
je suis plutôt en désaccord à ce
qu'avait dit monsieur le
alexandre emorine le responsable la
france a soumis ce monsieur marine mais
je trouve que en réalité les juges elle
ne cherche pas qu'à s'engager du tous
n'attendent pas du tout que ça et enfin
de deux comédies le
le journaliste kitambala les lions
menaient lignan le système les personnes
que vous avez ici c'est loin d'être
représentatif de de la totalité des
délits siens et pour la plupart c'est
les sujets même les plus ceux qui ont le
plus d'impact sur la vie de tous les
jours comme les gilets jaunes à hier ça
a bloqué mon train par exemple mais
enfin soit mais même pour ces sujets là
leur paraissent très lointain parce que
pour la plupart nous ont pas de lien
particulier ça n'impacte pas leur vie au
quotidien
tellement dans une sorte de stabilité
que au final boss s'est passé une
cherche pas qu'à s'engager du tout en
fait sont plus occupés par des choses
qui les concernent directement
pas forcément individualiste mais en
tout cas plus direct que des dés ce
genre de choses l'intérêt particulier
avant elle et ce n'était pas d'accord du
coup je suis plutôt sur le même point de
vue que shaheen c'est à dire que oui en
soi se regarde
d'un point de vue plus large il ya peu
de gens de notre tranche d'âge qui sont
intéressés par la politique mais je
pense qu'on n'est pas non plus un
échantillon très représentatif au final
de l'engagement des lycéens en politique
et moi quand je regarde autour de moi
c'est sûr que je peux pas rêver beaucoup
de personnes de ces sujets là mais
je vois où il veut en venir quand il
parle je demande manque
d'investissements politiques
alors elle les façons ruines fine
peut-être pas mais juste forcément quand
politique mais ça peut être aussi dans
d'autres enfin souvent ici donc
aujourd'hui c'est une émission politique
était fermée comme l'on dit ici est-ce
que ce que fait le cvl où les unes des
ailes etc
assad ça révèle conseil de la vie du
lycée de vie lycéenne et mdl maison des
lycéens
ça ça n'a pas de vocation politique ou
si on a un certain nombre de valeurs qui
sont celles de liberté égalité
fraternité qui sont imposés et on agit
dans le cadre de celle-ci mais ya pas de
s'agit pas de politiser en quoi que ce
soit c'est plus de 2 la représentation
directe des élèves pour des choses il te
raconterai qd ils traquent concrètes
pardon est donc en dehors de ça c'est
long
l'engagement ça peut être aussi sur
d'autres dans d'autres sujets thèmes
comme abella par exemple ou de houe et
on peut on ne sait pas c'est pas
toujours en politique où ça peut être à
travers des associations mais aussi ça
peut être un engagement moral personnel
ou avec un groupe informel créé parce
qu'ils me pas toujours du tout souvent
je trouve le plus en plus loin de la
politique
nous continuons à parler notamment tout
à l'heure avec maël puisque nous
évoquions les instances jeunes peut-être
dans les communes mais dans les
départements aussi les des conseils
départementaux jeunes ou encore un
parlement européen des jeunes belle nous
en parlera tout à l'heure dans la suite
puisque c'est là c'est un petit peu le
thème qu'on va aborder maintenant on
peut on peut rebondir
arnaud effectivement shine parlait de
politique ou pas politiques partis
politiques finalement qui qui plaisent
pas forcément qu'ils sont plus forcément
le le réceptacle où la voix préférée des
jeunes
c'est ce qu'on avait prévu effectivement
pour la suite de cette émission cette
impression que finalement aujourd'hui
les partis politiques c'est plus du tout
ce qui attire quand on a 18 ans vincent
chauvet vous disiez font mes amis et moi
quand j'étais jeune j'ai adhéré à figer
parti qui s'appelait l'udf on va dire
qu'aujourd'hui ce serait plus une
tendance lourde chez eux
qu'est-ce qui va pas entre les jeunes et
les partis politiques aujourd'hui que
c'est la fin des idées c'est que les
partis politiques ont trop souvent
utilisé les jeunes à des fins
très utilitaires comme on peut le dire
moi j'ai adhéré à l'udf pour une raison
et je suis resté au modem avec françois
bayrou pour une raison principale c'est
l'engagement européen c'est le parti le
plus pro européen et fédéralistes et
donc il était plus pour une cause que
pour un parti en tant que tel mais
aujourd'hui au niveau local on peut et
on doit s'engager sans parti politique
nos listes nos colistiers nos adjoints
le conseils municipaux dans nos mairies
sont souvent éloignés de tout parti
politique on peut dire aux jeunes
si vous voulez être élu dans votre ville
ou dans votre commune vous n'avez pas
besoin d'adhérer à un parti
vous avez montré que vous savez le
fédérer à des gens que vous portez
dévalant en même temps va sauver vous
appartenez vous même un parti vous êtes
maire si demain ou prochaines
municipales vous proposer des jeunes de
venir avec vous dans la rue on va leur
dire a battu suis une mère donc tu suis
un parti politique
non je crois pas parce que dans beaucoup
de communes y compris les communes de
plus de 10 mille habitants il ya la
plupart des listes qui sont d'intérêt
local et c'était la démarche de mon
prédécesseur d'ailleurs rémy rebeyrotte
de faire une liste d'intérêt local où il
y avait certes des gens qui portaient un
écusson politique mais vraiment un
spectre très large et dont beaucoup
beaucoup de communes et notamment les
communes rurales l'oublions pas qu il ya
trente-deux mille communes en france de
moins de 2000 habitants où on a des
mères est un ensemble de conseils
musical sans aucune étiquette qui sont
là pour faire travailler pour faire
marcher la commune est on est on est en
dehors des partis il a effectivement eu
la politique ce n'est pas forcément les
parties un maire rural où un maire même
d'une commune de 2000 habitants
c'est pas forcément un quelqu'un qui va
porter les couleurs d'un parti politique
et ça je pense que c'est important de le
dire aussi aux jeunes c'est que
l'importance de l'engagement c'est aussi
le sens de la responsabilité
gérer un budget savoir ce qu'on va faire
comme en plein conseil de la vie
lycéenne ça ressemble fortement à une
commune finalement cette initiation
absolument et avoir des revendications
on va parler des gilet jaune avoir des
revendications constructive réaliste qui
rentre dans le cadre légal on peut pas
demander moins de taxes et plus de
dépenses publiques
voilà nous rôle c'est parce qu'on est
dans l'action nous on sait que l'on a un
budget à gérer qu'on a des employés des
agents que l'on à des politiques
publiques a mené par fois l'engagement
dans la dans la jeunesse ça peut être un
engagement de révolte contre tous on est
ici dans le
et charles de gaulle avec un magnifique
magnifique buste du général je vais
perdre
le père de la vème république je pense
que c'est important de transmettre aux
jeunes générations et de rappeler
peut-être aux anciennes que nous sommes
dans un cadre constitutionnel d'un
cinquième république
on peut vouloir le changer mais
aujourd'hui c'est le cas avec une un
état de droit une légalité
quand on fait des actions il ya des
déclarations il ya des choses qui
doivent être dans les clous juridique et
puis on est dans une démocratie où les
élections qui sont assez souvent
convoqué nous permettre d'élire leurs
représentants ou d'échangé et il
faudrait pas laisser penser qu' on peut
tout faire n'importe comment qu'on peut
destituer le président de la république
qu'on peut avoir dans l'actualité
voilà qu'on peut avoir il ya des
revendications fortes et le pouvoir
d'achat en est une et il faut des gens
qui portent cette parole et des réponses
qui viennent apaiser cette colère mais
il faut savoir aussi que nous la
manifestation devrait déclarer qu'on
peut pas bloquer des ronds-points de
manière spontanée à toute heure du jour
et de la nuit et qu' il ya des élections
des colères doivent s'exprimer à
l'intérieur d'associations de syndicats
de partis politiques ou simplement hans
porte en soi même candidat dans sa
commune
sa région son départ message est passé
pour les jeunes autunois ce qu'il vaut
cancer justin cuir vous êtes issu du
parti socialiste d'un vieux parti est ce
que c est ce que les parties ont échoué
finalement quand on entend les jeunes
aujourd'hui
est ce que on est partis ont échoué est
ce que vous vous le ressentez parce que
vous êtes jeunes dans ce vieux parti
aussi justement je voudrais rebondir sur
ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure
il ya une tendance aussi à prendre des
jeunes des femmes pour être une sorte de
caution dans les listes municipales moi
j'en étais on va dire la principale
victime
puisqu'en 2014 on est venu me chercher
je n'avais pas forcément de conscience
politique je le dis et je les assume au
sens premier du terme et on m'a dit
effectivement tué une femme tuée jeunes
viendront dans ma liste
donc j'ai été 7e adjointe à la jeunesse
donc ce qui est plutôt intéressant
aujourd'hui est la première action que
j'ai souhaité mener au sein de ce mandat
d'adjoint était la création d'un conseil
municipal des jeunes j'en parle à mon
équipe et c'est donc une équipe
et âgées puisque effectivement on avait
quand même des conseils municipaux qui
sont relativement âgés
je leur jeu leur a dicté mon choix de
mettre en place le conseil municipal des
jeunes pour justement que les 2,6 oies
et notamment les jeunes de 6 mois soit
écouté soit entendu qu'on les écoute et
qu'on les responsabilise et ça a été un
refus catégorique sur quels points
bon pourquoi il voulait pas je n'ai
jamais su le fin mot de l'histoire mais
un refus catégorique alors peut-être
aussi une fracture générationnelle entre
des élus plutôt âgées qui ont qu'ils
avaient peur peut-être de faire
confiance aussi à cette jeunesse les
écoutes et peut-être aussi avoir de
nouvelles idées qui émergent
vincent chauvet parlait beaucoup des
réseaux sociaux c'est vrai que moi je
suis maire de decize et des réseaux
sociaux sont finalement très très peu
utilisé par la population parce qu'on a
une population qui est quand même
vieillissante on a beaucoup de retraités
beaucoup de personnes de plus de 70 ans
et c'est vrai que les réseaux sociaux
mois si demain je dis à la population
que je me rends place en danse nachat
ils vont regarder avec des grands viande
dix ans mais de quoi il s'agit donc
c'est vrai que je pense qu'il ya aussi
une déconnexion sur sur le terrain moi
je leur centre une jeunesse qui est
vraiment je dirais dans une nouvelle ère
et des personnes plutôt âgées qui
comprennent pas qu'ils ne comprennent
pas donc il ya vraiment une fracture
générationnelle mais il faut pas trop
parler de partis politiques dans ce que
vous faites c'est un repoussoir pour les
jeunes avec qui vous travaillez non
après on peut essayer mais je pense que
le but
enfin pour communiquer avec les jeunes
ne suffit pas de dire ouais je poste un
truc sur un sauna pour faire un gramme
il ya plus de faim il ya tellement de
contenus qu'il faut sortir du lot pour
justement faut donner envie à ces jeunes
voleurs leur permettre de pouvoir rêver
de de s'approcher de ce qu'ils veulent
mais pas trop fin juste milieu faut pas
non plus trop les chercher leur donner
cette habitude justement de deux trous
venue de troyes aller les chercher
parce que à prix vont devenir un peu
fainéant mais justement il faut leur
montrer que faut que ça vienne aut 6 2
mais pour te pour sa veine de il faut
leur donner envie il faut que justement
trouvé ce petit ce petit truc pour pour
qu'il vienne par eux mêmes et ça marche
ce qu'on commençait avec vous il
continue et ils font plus de choses
après vous avez du recul là dessus bien
sûr bien sûr
9 au début c'était compliqué parce que
je sais pas du tout comment
à l'espace et finalement ça a très bien
marché parce qu'on a su justement leur
donner envie et aujourd'hui ils ont créé
leur propre truc sans que je leur dise
en fait ils ont créé leur propre groupe
ils ont ils ont fonctionné comme ça
depuis maintenant fin à reporter des
prix nationaux enfin grâce au film
saleuses à lézat motive encore plus donc
ils ont vu qu'il y avait des résultats
c'est aussi ça qui est important c'est
de voir qu'il ya des résultats derrière
pas forcément que c'est venu tout seul
en fait j'ai même pas eu besoin de leur
dire que l'on va pouvoir faire changer
les choses ils l'ont vu par eux mêmes
parce que on a su incorporer tout ça
dans le contenu est en fait y'a pas eu
besoin de trop parler c'est ça s'est
fait tout seul alors on parlait des vous
parliez de conseil municipal des jeunes
de toutes les instances qui peuvent
exister en préparant cette émission avec
les jeunes c'est quelque chose qui
ressortit auxquelles on n'avait pas
pensé
c'est cette impression arnaud parfois
quand on est jeune on n'est pas
réellement représenté par réellement
pris en compte est ce que on a des
choses à dire avec vous là où
effectivement des élus souvent plus âgés
que la génération en faut-il être jeune
pour reparler des questions des jeunes
peut-être pas forcément va en discuter
mais yasmin avait une question sur cette
action et partis politiques une question
directement à vincent chauvet yasmine
oui mais si j'avais dit ne pas
représenter les couleurs de son parti
dans le cadre de sa fonction
donc dans ce cas là que représentait à
quoi sert son engagement au sein du
parti auquel il adhère question
s'appelle une réponse est excellente
question est ce qu'on peut être dans un
parti politique sur des grandes idées
piller être maire sans étiquette
politique
je pense que il faut avoir des valeurs
qui guident l'engagement et qui guident
les actions
j'ai des valeurs j'ai dit pro européenne
pour la démocratie pour la laïcité pour
l'égalité hommes femmes pour la
protection des minorités
et puis au jour le jour ses valeurs
guides même et ne dicte pas ce que ce
qu'on va faire
quand on décide de faire une piste
d'athlétisme ou un parc public
on a derrière l'idée qu' il est
important que tout le monde puisse avoir
accès au sport il est important que dans
les quartiers populaires on puisse aussi
donner un cadre de vie agréable
mais ensuite c'est des choix qui peuvent
être faits par des maires de différentes
tendances et on sait qu'un bon maire
doit pas être jugée par le fait qu'ils
soient de telle ou telle couleur mais
par ses résultats ses actions concrètes
et comment il porte sa au niveau de sa
population
on a des mers caricaturaux et dans notre
département il y en a quelques-uns en
saône et loire qui eux sont idéologues
et qui vont prendre des décisions
simplement pour faire de la provocation
pour faire plaisir à leur camp mais ça
ça je pense que c'est pas forcément les
maires que les habitants souhaitent ce
qu'ils souhaitent c'est quelqu'un qui
soit au service de la population qui
répondent à leurs attentes qui gère au
mieux le budget qui essaye de faire
baisser les taxes ou qui essaie d'amener
le meilleur service public et ça c'est
pas quelque chose de politique mais moi
je regrette le fait d'avoir d'avoir
quelque chose qui me motive à m'engager
parce que quand on est là sept jours sur
sept et qu' il faut se lever le matin
pour aller à dijon et puis après
remettre des récompenses et puis après
aller à l'avant première d'un film et
puis après aller à un dîner et puis ça
tous les jours être en représentation
être en réunion il faut aussi que l'on
est chevillée au corps l'intérêt général
et ça peut venir d'une cause les
réfugiés le réchauffement climatique ou
d'un engagement politique mais dans le
concret d'un élu local le parti
politique ne joue absolument pas alors
voilà on a eu la réponse de la salle
chauffée et donc la question c'est où
sont les jeunes finalement arnaud ils
sont là ils sont bien là on évoqué
l'engagement politique peut être dès le
plus jeune âge peut-être dans un conseil
municipal des jeunes un conseil
départemental
maël ce serait intéressant qui nous
parle de cette expérience peut-être
est-ce que tu as eu l'impression dans un
conseil départemental des jeunes
auxquels tu as a participé de changer
des choses d'avoir eu vraiment des
décisions à prendre
peut-être sans doute pour la jeunesse
avant tout alors en premier lieu j'étais
au conseil département le thaï avant
conseiller général en 5e 4e donc à cet
âge là on n'a pas trop la maturité de se
dire on va changer les choses
effectivement on a fait une campagne
contre le harcèlement scolaire
alors c'est possible harcèlement et tout
ça et c'est ça va vraiment apporter
quelque chose mais c'est à pas on
n'avait pas d'opinion politique ou quoi
que ce soit des choses qui vous concerne
vous à vous de votre agent fait
oui c'est ça c'était plus voilà à cette
époque là on était plus pour nous voilà
qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait ce qu'on peut
faire pour nous mais c'était plus dans
une ambiance festive et pas quelque
chose
voilà on voulait pas changer la société
on voulait agir un petit peu et puis
voir qu'est ce que ça faisait alors
aujourd'hui pour s'informer il ya quoi
il y as peut-être avant tout les réseaux
sociaux est ce que vous consultez votre
portable à tout-va quand une information
est publiée est ce que c'est la proue le
première chose le premier réflexe de
consulter son téléphone d'aller voir sur
les réseaux sociaux peut être aussi
comment vous faites oui je pense que
tout d'abord il ya instagram instagram
les choses comme ça on peut suivre des
personnalités comme les personnalités
politiques on peut suivre le monde qui
publie souvent les choses
du coup on peut se tenir au courant de
l'actualité après c'est quand même
important d'avoir diverses sources de
l'information pour pas être que dans une
queue dans une optique et que voir les
points négatifs de quelque chose
voilà faut avoir plusieurs sources pour
pouvoir débattre entre guillemets avec
soi même pour se dire mais qu'est ce qui
se passe vraiment oui alors entre vous
par exemple oui alors moi je privilégie
les médias qui sont plutôt neutre à
savoir par exemple la télé là les
chaînes d'état comme france 2 ou à
savoir aussi les l'application comme
france tv info qui donne des
désinformations voilà plus notre
possible je trouve du coup je à partir
de ça je peux former mon opinion alors
juste une petite précision chaîne de
service public et la chaîne d'état va
mal on l apprécie également faire une
mission auprès du public en tout cas
merci et c'était pas du tout un sous la
contrainte que tu nous dis ça le site
par exemple installer un fossé en face
c'est une application qui envoie des
notifications tout au long de la journée
qui est donc là pour notre public est
très très très adapté aux jeunes je
trouve qu'ils sont très sûrs les sur les
portables et les smartphones et qui
veulent tous savoir rapidement un peu
comme nous tous finalement aujourd'hui
les lions sur ce sujet là vous qu'être
mère ou
militant ou engagé dans l'associatif
quel sentiment vous avez on va redire
une deuxième fois que peut-être des
jeunes qui s'informent beaucoup sur le
monde sur france info sont pas forcément
aujourd'hui juste une grue représentatif
de tous les jeunes
même à l'échelon d'une commune on parle
beaucoup c'est un peu la mode mais
défectueuse des du complotisme ces
choses là est ce que c'est des choses
que vous ressentez à l'échelle d'une
commune c'est vrai que moi j'ai mon
encore une fois je le dis je pense qu'il
ya quand même une différence importante
entre des jeunes d'un lycée de dijon et
des jeunes d'un lycée de 2,6 alors je
veux absolument pas dit mais c'est aussi
pour ça qu'on a qu'on a pâti tout ça de
cette manière là pour avoir plusieurs
j'ai absolument pas dire que les jeunes
de 2,6 sont moins bien que ceux de dijon
mais je pense qu'effectivement la
réalité pas la même
souvent les environnements aussi sont
différents on a aussi dans la nièvre un
environnement social qui est quand même
très pauvre il faut le dire
et donc on se rend compte aussi que la
réalité politique elle est intimement
liée aussi à la réalité sociale et c'est
pour ça que je pense que dans le sud
nivernais spécifiquement on a des jeunes
qui sont totalement désintéressé de la
politique parce que pas d'emploi parce
que pas d'argent pour pour s'informer
il y en a certains moi j'ai rencontré
les jeunes qui à 25 ans n'ont pas de
permis de conduire n'ont pas de
smartphone donc ça c'est des réalités et
je ne sais pas si vincent chauvet a les
mêmes problématiques à autun mais nous
enfin - tant que maire je reçois
quotidiennement des jeunes qui sont
vraiment en souffrance qui n'ont pas
d'accès à quoi que ce soit et qui se
sentent vraiment
laissé pour compte et donc avec une
compréhension du monde qui les entoure
assez compliqué du coup oui et puis je
pense qu'ils sont quand même
désabusé voilà ils sont désabusés ils
ont l'impression que personne ne les
écoute et quand j'ai reçu un jet n'y a
pas très longtemps il m'a dit de toute
façon je n'irai jamais voter puisque
pourquoi voter moi ça fait trente ans
que je grandis dans un environnement
très pauvre et personne ne nous a aidés
et c'est vraiment c'est vraiment une
tranche de la population qui n'est qui
n'est pas négligeable vous acquiescez
alexandre et marina que oui oui tout à
fait ça revient à ce que disait tout à
l'heure sur le fait que les anciens
partis avaient déçu quand j'entrerai
monsieur chauvet à dire enfin vraiment
que que selon vous l'engagement ne passe
que par partis associations syndicats je
pense qu'aujourd'hui ces structures ils
ont montré leurs limites
aussi c'est toujours efficace bien
entendu dans une certaine mesure mais
pas seulement quand vous avez par
exemple des jeunes à marseille qui voit
une école maternelle donc c'était jeunes
parents qui voient une école maternelle
qui complètement délabré la mairie s'en
fout totalement depuis des années et là
qu'est ce qu'ils font ils font eux mêmes
ils prennent sur leurs week-ends et
quand ils rénovent eux mêmes leur école
donc ça c'est quelque chose
les pouvoirs publics n'ont rien fait
donc je comprends totalement quand
certains disent qu'ils sont abandonnés
par les pouvoirs publics parce que en
l'occurrence c'est le cas il ya
également d'autres structures qui se
forme en parler de comment la politique
peut parler aux jeunes le parlement par
exemple le parlement c'est encore
quelque chose qui est très obscur
l'assemblée nationale le sénat comment
parler à la jeunesse est bien la
jeunesse quelqu'un sait ce qu'elle fait
et se créent des outils sur internet
vous avez sur twitch des chaînes qui
parle qui commentent les questions à
l'assemblée nationale qui commet qui
pose des questions aux sénateurs qui qui
permettent d'avoir un de démultiplier
l'accès de la jeunesse de la jeunesse à
la question politique et enfin pour
revenir sur les questions de
l'engagement aussi sur le fait que la
jeunesse construit ses propres
structures
il ya eu un événement historique quand
même il ya deux semaines en france
ça s'appelle aussi event une communauté
de joueurs de jeux vidéo pendant 50
heures qui diffuse en direct sur
internet leurs partis qui appellent leur
public à faire des dons et c'est un
public est donc très jeune et ce public
a réussi à réunir 1 million d'euros au
profit de msf sur un week end sur 50
heures et là sans passer par des
structures
sans passer par une défiscalisation ou
un ou un intérêt individuellement
complètement de manière désintéressée
donc la jeunesse elle secret ces
structures aujourd'hui parce que les
structures de la société ne sont pas
adaptés à son son mode de vie à son mode
de fonctionnement
j'étais le père réagit pile nantes va
aller on parlait aussi effectivement
d'informations aussi milieu on en
parlait vous vous faites des films avec
eux donc ça veut dire que vous leur
apprenez aussi à comprendre que ce
qu'ils voient parfois ou ce qu'ils
lisent sur les réseaux sociaux ce qui
suivent juste pas juste vous allez dans
cette dimension éducative ou en tout cas
vous vous rendez compte qu'il faut le
faire de temps en temps je pense que
c'est important de sensibiliser les
jeunes par rapport à ça de leur montrer
que souvent c'est pas toujours ce qu'on
sait pas toujours la réalité en fait
parce que on le voit qu'une partie sur
les réseaux sociaux qui peut changer la
vie de tout le monde
après là où je voulais un thé réagir je
sais que c'était vraiment des jeux vidéo
si je mets l'instant juste mais c'était
par rapport il faut pas oublier qu'il ya
aussi des personnes qui s'engagent et
qui sont pas forcément sur les réseaux
sociaux qui a beaucoup de personnes qui
s'engagent
moi j'en connais plein mais qui n'aime
pas se montrait forcément et je pense
que les réseaux sociaux c'est juste un
moyen justement d'avoir plus des d'avoir
plus de portes ouvertes et c'est pour ça
qu'il y en a beaucoup qui essaient
réellement d'avoir injustement d'être
visible sur les réseaux sociaux c'est
pour avoir plus d aide mais il ya
beaucoup de personnes qui n'ont pas
besoin de ça qui n'aime pas se montrer
donc faut pas oublier qu'il ya des
personnes qui sont engagées mais qui ne
sont pas pourquoi pas voilà ça arnaud
réseaux sociaux est ce que ça inspire
chez vous oui l'information forcément
yasmine oui ben pour l'information moi
je pense que quelle que soit la manière
de s'informer par les réseaux sociaux
les journaux la radio pour nous en tant
que jeune lycéen il est nécessaire de se
tenir au courant de l'actualité pour
mener à bien nos études en fait pour
mener à bien notre notre année scolaire
et ça fait partie de notre engagement
c'est un outil de travail aussi
finalement cette matière de
l'information ça veut dire que par
exemple au bac ça peut ressortir dans
les copies dans les devoir de philo ou
d'autres bien sûr c'est un outil
fondamental ne serait ce que par exemple
nous on est en es pour l'économie dans
les introductions c'est nécessaire et
indispensable
tout au long de l'année tu penses ça
tient dans ma dit sorte d'écho dans mon
devoir des causes ça peut me servir sa
note à ce sujet non je le fais déjà par
moi-même même avant j'écoutais beaucoup
la radio etc et ça ne sert en plus pour
les cols donc c'est génial
grégoire oui mais le jeu donc concernant
l'information
ce que nous recherchons les jeunes c'est
l'accessibilité ainsi que la rapidité
est donc ce qui est le plus facile et le
plus accessible pour nous de nos jours
eh ben c'est d'aller sur son smartphone
c'est pas d'allumer la télé c'est
d'avoir regardé une application même des
notifications qu'on reçoit on peut aussi
regarder la télé sur son smartphone on
peut aussi mais le plus simple est ce
qui est de mieux en mieux que les
réseaux sociaux notamment
c'est que c'est de plus en plus
restreint je m'explique c'est de plus en
plus courts c'est à dire que sur paris
match at comme le format et de quelques
secondes on va à l'essentiel sur twitter
de la même manière ce n'est que 140
caractères donc on va à chaque fois
l'essentiel on ne perd pas de temps à
lire un article de beaucoup de pages et
qu'on l'a on résume en quelques phrases
jouant quelques en quelques mots on
parlait de l'application par exemple
d'un quotidien comme le monde
là on a des articles un peu plus loin un
peu plus de fond donc on fait le grand
écart entre le message effectivement 120
caractères ou 280 sur twitter et
l'article qu'on prend le temps de lire
et on le lit aussi sur son smartphone
n'est pas sur une version papier j'ai
constaté notamment avec le monde sait
que ils ont réduit quand même par
rapport à avant le
le format est il s'adresse c'est mieux
en mieux voilà à quoi bon fois une
analyse de l'évolution des médias
vincent chauvet vous voulez réagir sur
sur deux choses notamment les réseaux
sociaux c'est pas seulement un moyen
d'information c'est aussi un moyen de
communication et de communication
directe avec les élus les jeunes élus
que nous sommes est
et justement l'exemple de marseille est
très bon parce que je pense que ça
impossible que ça se passe à 2,6 ou out
parce que nous des cas une tuile qui
tombe dans un préau
on a un message facebook j'en ai eu ce
matin à 8 heures avant de venir d'une
auto école qui voulaient venir me voir
pour un problème et donc on est
directement accessible et les jeunes
n'hésitent pas et on répond que c'est
fait pour ça a contacté par facebook ou
par mail pour nous dire voilà il ya
quelque chose qui se passe et on sait
que dans des villes où ça se passe moins
bien marseille et aussi du logement
insalubre etc qui peut ce qui peut se
développer
et puis ce qui a dit la mère de 2,6
également sur ces jeunes en décrochage
moi je les vois aussi dans le territoire
de l'autunois morvan qui est pas si loin
de la nièvre où je suis président de la
mission locale à l'échelle de toute la
communauté de communes et du nord-ouest
du département et où on voit
effectivement ces problèmes de permis de
conduire ses problèmes de confiance en
soi de maîtrise du français de perte
d'orientation des genres qui à qui on a
qu on a marre l'orienter qui savent pas
quoi faire de mobilité évidemment
d'accès en voiture et donc il ya un
certain nombre de dispositifs qui sont
mis en place notamment la garantie
jeunes qui est un outil très efficace et
je fais souvent des interventions au
civisme ou à la citoyenneté dans ces
groupes de la garantie jeunes en leur
expliquant si vous avez 400 euros par
mois c'est parce que c'est l'union
européenne le fonds social européen qui
vous finance
si vous avez de l'aide au permis de
conduire c'est la région qui vous
finance
si vous êtes dans des locaux et que vous
avez des tables et des chaises c'est la
ville penser que ça on voit les noms
mais la garantie jeune je pense que dans
la campagne européenne il faudra dire et
répéter que la garantie
alors qu'elle commence parce que ces
métaux et qui vont rester des missions
en perdition je pense qu'ils touchent du
doigt ce qu'une politique publique est
et comment on dépense de l'argent public
pour les raccrocher pour leur permettre
d'avoir le permis de conduire etc des
lunes régionaux
bientôt à la fin de cette émission
arnaud c'est peut-être le moment de se
quitter et de se dire ce dont ils se
donnent aux lycéens en vie ou comment il
voit l'avenir
peut-être n'at-il parmi vous qui
envisage de se présenter peut-être aux
european aux municipales ou président de
la république ne s'est pas est-ce qu'il
y en a des ambitions politiques qui sont
nés pendant cette émission qui vont
continuer à grandir
shane non pas du peuple d'une
supposition mais peut-être de manière
plus générale par rapport à ce que dit
monsieur vincent chauvet c'est que plus
tôt dans l'émission par rapport aux
listes électorales un peut-être un autre
frein une ligne dès que pour que pour
interpréter pourquoi les jeunes ne
veulent pas s'engager dans notre tranche
d'âge
enfin est-ce que ce que l'eau j'ai pu
constater la sna ça n'engage que moi
c'est que souvent on a on associe
énormément le la personne à son parti à
la structure dans laquelle ils rentrent
c'est à dire que c'est laid c'est à
l'individu de s'associer de de ce2
d'entrer dans le moule c'est pas les
individus qui forment le moule et en
plus de ça il ya tout cia toute cette
histoire de séparation de la vie privée
des personnes la vie publique comme l'a
dit le responsable associatif
c'est qu'il ya énormément de personnes
qui veulent et qui s'engage et qui vint
côme d'olt sens que vous avez défini et
qui font des choses mais qui veulent pas
que ce soit connue qui veulent pas qu'on
part de leur vie privée ils veulent pas
que leurs visages soient soient publics
qui veulent pas que leur nom soit connu
et qui font pourtant peut-être beaucoup
plus de choses que tu les autres
personnes réunies qu'on connaît et c'est
plus souvent le cas chez nous les jeunes
et est souvent est un autre frein c'est
que on voit toutes ces personnes qui se
font détruire dans les médias ou sur les
réseaux alors qu'on a et c'est pas
forcément très attractif de voir sa vie
privée mêlant de voir la vie privée les
autres mélangez alors ça donne pas
forcément très envie
ce sera le mot de la fin pour cette
partie là en tout cas effectivement
engagement dans la vie de la société
mais pas forcément jusqu'à l'engagement
politique c'est ce qu'on retiendra ici
avec ses élèves de terminale en forme de
conclusion effectivement il nous reste
très peu de temps on entendu dans son
show verts on vous a entendu un dernier
tout petit mot en quelques secondes the
things you you
ça vous c'est quelque chose qui est dans
votre tête réussir à parler aux jeunes
quand on est maire ouais il faut réussir
à parler aux jeunes
mais je pense aussi qu'il faut pas
s'adresser qu'aux jeunes il faut pas
créer un clivage entre les générations
effectivement on crée des conseils
municipaux des jeunes ont créé des
structures spécifiquement pour les
jeunes mais je pense qu'il faut avant
tout réussir à faire un lien entre les
générations
et ben voilà ce sera la conclusion de
notre émission merci à tous d'être
d'être venu ici merci aux élèves merci à
leur professeur véronique pro tyler
proviseur jean claude monier marriott
qui nous ont ouvert largement des portes
de cet établissement bon dimanche
au revoir et merci